Cleveland's had a bad offseason and it's
getting worse because now the report is
or reports are that Kyrie Irving went in
talked to management and would like to
like to be traded Joe vardhan's been
working on this story doing great work
for Cleveland calm covering the Cavs and
he joins us now Joe how did this
information get leaked in the first
place do we have any idea the source or
sources yes I'm not telling you okay all
right but at least you know okay all
right fair enough all right why would
somebody leaked it well I think even to
answer that I think would would you know
put various people in compromising
situations but you know you you have to
remember that this was a meeting between
Kyrie and carries agent and Dan Gilbert
and and an ownership and and that's
where the meeting started so at some
point you know Dan or the people who
worked for Dan you know shared this
information within the organization and
I'm not even sure that Kyrie expected
that so you know things happen from
there and and I and I really think you
know the Kyrie went and went into this
probably expecting that this
conversation be totally you know between
them and yet at the same time after they
had it you know Dan in the front office
began to quietly try to put together
trade scenarios so you know I don't know
how long
Kyrie could have reasonably expected
this to remain quiet and it just so
happened to broke while he was on his
goodwill tour with Nike which wasn't
ideal for him okay but why do you see
one out
so you know I mean you guys only have a
finite amount of time between you know
breaks here it's a very long store
it gets into trying to understand just
who Kyrie Irving is and what he sees for
himself he wants out because he feels he
is ready to be the focal point of a
franchise and he knows that that is not
going to be the case this year in
Cleveland that's that's the simple
answer but obviously you know there's so
many yeah buts and what-ifs and wise and
you know it's really a fascinating case
but Joe if the feeling the consensus is
LeBron is not going to be there and more
than one more year then wouldn't Kyrie
Irving inherit the team and then it
would become his team and he would be
the man right Danah and I'm glad you
said that because that is to me that is
the biggest misnomer out there when you
talk about this whole Kyrie LeBron thing
Kyrie and his visions for his career
have nothing to do with what LeBron
James is going to do next year or not in
terms of Cleveland if it if it did then
then you would you could only surmise
that Kyrie kind of sees LeBron staying
in Cleveland because otherwise you he
knows he'd be inheriting a team where he
could have the Super Max you know make
over 200 million dollars a year you know
they're not a year excuse me but over
the life of a contract you know they
could build a team around him like all
that stuff all that stuff and he knows
that it's one year away a year after
where he would go to the sports straight
finals maybe win as we all know once you
get there you never know and instead
he's walking away from all of that why
it's because of what he sees for himself
and what he wants to do for himself
beyond merely I say merely but beyond
just getting to another Finals and
staying with LeBron and winning games in
Cleveland it's more - there's more to
the picture for him well you did bring
up something interesting that that maybe
there is a feeling now that our Kyrie
feels that LeBron
staying in Cleveland you know that that
would add to his Exodus that you know
I'm I would be able to say that would be
the the logical way to become the man
but maybe he feels like LeBron is is
going to stay in Cleveland we've heard
the country but why do we assume LeBron
is going to leave well I don't i do not
assume he's going to leave i say always
that it is me you know i'm careful here
but it is more likely than not that he
stays is there a chance to leave
absolute ass is there a chance to leave
absolutely there is does he know what
he's going to do he does not does almost
all of this depend on how good the Cavs
are this year and what happens in the
finals is it close do they make it there
to begin with all that yes but you know
LeBron has only said publicly that he
would finish his career here and he
knows that there would be some backlash
to going against that and he also you
know the contract matters to him not in
terms of the money as far as like I need
to have this you know 209 million dollar
deal for my bank account but in terms of
legacy you know there was a reason that
he sank that he congratulated Steph
Curry when step nine is 201 million
dollar deal and it's not because they're
buddies it's because you know LeBron
seeds you know he sees things that are
legacy builders and being able to sign
the single largest contract in history
you know even hardens contracts four to
twenty seven or eight or whatever it is
that's an extension and the extension is
worth like 170 plots so this would be
the single largest one-time contracting
history to LeBron times this summer that
matters to him to a bunch of other stuff
matters to him as well and again it
isn't there is a chance he leaves but I
don't believe that I don't believe that
we should assume that he leaves right
now talking to Jill Barden NBA reporter
for cleveland.com covering the Cavs is
there a chance what's the likelihood
that the cat's start the season with
Kyrie Irving
the backcourt I mean I I just don't I
don't see it I don't see I don't see how
they how that happens yeah because of
you know I think just the the raw
feelings that are that are around
everywhere you know with LeBron with
Kyrie with the opportunity that now
exists to change the team you know they
obviously felt going into this offseason
that they wanted to try to change the
team they tried to do it by trading
Kevin instead of Kyrie but they want to
try to get younger they want to acquire
some some pieces that they feel they
need to go after the Warriors you would
think Kyrie would fit into that but if
they can move him to get some of these
pieces that would help that that is what
they want to do and they are you know
confident that they can you know the
other thing is how LeBron feels about
this he obviously was upset you know not
only that you know every source talking
to whether it was me or to Bryan
Windhurst who both the story or whoever
all the sources indicated that and then
of course LeBron you know did his
Instagram post with that song and all
that stuff so he he was really said
about it then it was be hard to imagine
that you would bring Kyrie Irving back
and make them play together in that
awkward situation if LeBron is really
upset you know is there's time to bury
the hatchet sure but I just I see them
making a move are you going to get
dollar for dollar now that you know that
Kyrie wants out if I'm a team and I and
I'm going to trade for Kyrie am I giving
you full value for Kyrie Irving this
isn't similar to Paul George but all
George saying look I'm not going to sign
here I want to go to the Lakers
eventually whatever you do with me
here's Kyrie saying I want to be the man
so how much of the Cavalier is going to
get returned for Kyrie Irving why they
would and should get a great deal in
return
and they do reserve you know I
understand what I just told you on the
answer before but they do reserve the
right to not trade him and wait for the
right deal that comes along but there
are going to be good deals out there now
that they can get you know when you talk
about dollar for dollar you know full
value I think in some ways that's hard
to determine and the curry is a
four-time all-star he's a killer in the
clutch he's virtually unguardable but
some of that stuff happened with you
know like see he came into his own in
some ways playing alongside LeBron so
he's not a great defender you can get
players who obviously aren't as skilled
offensively as him but but can be better
defenders if you want to go the point
guard round I know they just signed Rose
or you can get somebody maybe try to get
somebody like an Andrew Wiggins or
somebody who is young you know plays a
different position but could be really
good for a really long time and can give
you things other things that you don't
have like you know trying to keep this
file straight together it's amazing were
they getting Derrick Rose no matter what
was happening with Kyrie Irving or is
this a reaction to the Kyrie Irving
situation see and the heart I I don't
know what to believe there because you
know you ask people close to Derrick did
did you know that this whole Kyrie thing
was coming down when the cab started
these discussions and the answer is no
but if the Cavs knew about Derrick Rose
on July 7th which is what is being
reported and that is virtually
impossible to believe and I just and so
now you know like if it was always about
winning for Derrick certainly it's
obviously not about the money he took
the minimum then you could say yeah he
was coming
even no matter what but the combination
of you know a chance to win and starting
on the cabs I think would be way too
much to pass up so it's hard day into
that good stuff Joe I'm going to stay
busy the rest of the summer that's for
sure we appreciate you joining us thanks
fancy traveling that's Joe Barden NBA
reporter cleveland.com
the Dan Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience